what's going on with you and all this um
ghost story in the sense that this is a
very heavy thing for me because i'm you
know as i get up in years i'm hoping
there's some sort of afterlife i don't
think there is
but you give me hope you give me hope
sammy you know there's something going
on howard i don't know what it is but
you know i've been touched in weird ways
sometimes in dreams and and while i'm
awake and you're thinking it's a dream
and
things happen my father visited me my
manager when he died visited me the
night they died but wait a second it's
deeper than that sammy what you're
saying is if i have it right your father
hard drinking man
uh tough guy dying under a park bench
basically i mean in the back of a car a
police car but they pull him out from a
park bench you know what i mean and the
night he dies there's a knock on your
door you hear a distinct knock you were
sleeping or you were awake i got up and
answered the door right
and in my and
in my house right where i was the person
that was with me my baby was then i had
a little two-year-old aaron his little
two-year-old boy and uh i answered the
door and i said it was my dad he was
like in his 20s and he was drunk and
going crazy and he was saying great
david the irish and all this stuff and i
said don't ever come like this in front
of my baby woke him up and it all
happened it was like a dream slam the
door went and laid back down
god's truth i mean you can't make this
[ __ ] up no and and the doc somebody
knocked on the door and i go
[ __ ] he's back i went and opened the
door and it was my next-door neighbor
who had a telephone that was an
emergency number for my sister my family
because i was living you know i was with
my band we were all sleeping in the same
house and all that same room anyway he
goes hey your sister's on the phone
yeah
look howard my fur is up you got
goosebumps yeah i do all over my body
man and so i just went
wow my sister i i knew i mean she said
they they found out they're four o'clock
in the morning you know it's
unbelievable it is unbelievable and
that's happening do you ever think since
it's happened
do you think maybe you were asleep or
you know you were awake when your father
visited you
i don't know
that's too out there man
uh i i was the second time it happened
well my my manager ed leffler uh who
when i joined van halen when i got
thrown out of you know when we were
having our hard times ed lefler had died
after that the band broke up and ed
lefter was my manager forever and then
he took over van halen and um
he just
i was sitting there we were going
through hell with the band
and they had hired this manager guy who
they ended up suing and all this stuff
we won't mention names but long story
short i talked about in my book and ed i
was sitting there i was laying in bed
and and i was just i just didn't know
what to do i i didn't want to quit the
band but i knew it was over you know we
were really at odds and ed comes to me
kneels down next to me in my bed i'm
going [ __ ] i'm smelling he's a cigarette
smoker you know we he had a certain
smell about him you know and uh i'm
going damn man what am i doing he said
don't worry about it it's gonna be okay
man he says
you know i mean he just came and flat
said that and just straightened me right
out i said bucket the next thing i know
i was thrown out of the band and it life
was good for me you know right like so
do you believe in the afterlife
uh yeah i'm doing dimensions yeah i
think there's a lot going on right
between raleigh writing history why is
everything happening to you and not me i
don't understand i lay in bed nothing
happened nobody visits you can have this
[ __ ] does it scare you when it comes
thank you
it's scary were you visited by aliens as
well yeah and i had a ufo experience and
that was in 67 68. and you weren't high
or anything no i didn't do drugs i
didn't even drink back then and who
visited they just randomly picked me and
i woke up while they were doing it i'm
going what the [ __ ] is going on my room
was white i mean i was like i couldn't
see anything was a complete whiteout i
later couldn't move all of a sudden they
said in another language just telepathy
uh this is done you know he's waking up
or whatever and and they yelled a
numerical code that was obviously you
know like your your passcode to get into
your [ __ ] you know and boom it was like
it was almost like a wire in the air and
when i woke up and it was black and i
was shaking and i couldn't move and when
you
yeah when you tell that story guys like
jason look at you like you're crazy he's
back there making hand signals like
cuckoo he's jealous he's jealous why
aren't you jealous i've never heard that
story yeah well he's been visited why
him i just kept thinking like did they
like
do sexual things did they put a catheter
up your penis no no they it wasn't
physical it was it was from a distance
they they they programmed into me they
like you know they wireless they were do
you think they programmed that you would
one day be the lead singer of a band no
no i think it that opened my mind it was
like a big acid trip brother